ladies and gentlemen everyone knows
there hasn't been a lot of good that's
come
of code but one silver lining i have to
say that i
personally enjoyed is watching these
fraudsters get
caught by the it's like a mouse trap
almost that was the ppp loans
i mean i'm convinced that maybe this was
a cia or fbi hit
job on fraudsters because basically it
went like this i have a little i
mocked up a little image for you guys
okay because they set out this bait
super easy to get ppp loans you can lie
you get as much money as you want
basically and then it's all the
fraudsters
they're just licking their chops like
they're loving the idea of free money
and then the doj is like
i mean i swear dude i read the doj's
website regularly now
businessmen read the newspaper i read
the doj's press releases that's what i
do that in the sec
because it's so crazy the high drama the
people they catch
are such characters and that's what i
want to talk about today that's what
this show is dedicated to welcome to the
ppp chronicles
roll the intro something like the lie
about the size of the puppy's and they
will be cut
or they will be god and if you have a
small ppp that is okay
but you must not lie to the government
not the government
maybe a new girlfriend
welcome to the peep chronicles ladies
and gentlemen this is martin cow he's
from hawaii and he has been accused of
stealing
or scamming whatever you want to call it
12 million dollars
from banks in federal stimulus money
you'd never expect it look he just looks
like a nice little businessman he runs a
little uh
defense contractor company martin cow
received over 12.8 million dollars
of paycheck protection program funds for
navitech
through fraud yeah that's gonna get you
on the show
for sure when i started looking to his
case more i was actually
fascinated by this too because the fact
he really thought he was gonna get away
with this and when you read the court
case it's insane
because this is one of those guys and i
love when people think that they're
powerful and they're not
he's one of those guys who thinks he has
political clout and political power
because he's donated a few hundred
thousand dollars to political campaigns
now nothing wrong with that
and it may give you a little shout out
from a small-time mayor or something
but that ain't big money you know the
people we sometimes cover
on the show some of them do have real
political power people like amway
dude are you kidding betsy devos heiress
to the amway name i mean she's literally
the secretary of education
that's real political power this guy
though
thinks he has political power but
doesn't so i gotta show you this case
file because i swear dude this guy
is like a male karen okay because the
banks
who he's submitting loans through
they're starting to give him trouble
as he's trying to fraudulently uh get
covet money
they're starting to ask for a bunch of
documentation and he's not happy about
it
and the reason for that is simple he
lied about how many employees he had to
try to get more money from the
government though he's real
nervous when they're processing his
application he's worried that he's not
going to get the money
and so he starts to try to flex on him
he starts to pull
the care and move of calling calling
your boss calling your manager or in
this case name dropping a senator
cal stated that he works very closely
with specified u.s senators and expected
to provide an update
shortly to each of them so he's saying
guys hey by the way you know eubank
who's trying to prove my loan i work
with the people who pro
who made this law right cal stated that
he strongly urged the cpb
to process his company's application as
quickly as possible
this is the kind of guy who can never
stop bringing up at a dinner party that
he knows a senator he's very close to
the senator
then five days later okay it's not even
that long later he gets a little antsy
and he goes i just got off a couple
calls with a u.s senator and member of
congress
they specifically asked about the status
of our ppp loan application and were
very adamant about stepping
in if our application was stalled oh
yeah i'm kind of a big deal
yeah they actually want to personally
intervene on my behalf
dude this guy thinks that just because
he gave a senator a little bit of money
he controls them and this is the thing
about power you often find that the
people who are on the biggest power
trips
have only gotten a small amount of power
he's yeah he's the ceo of a defense
contractor yeah he maybe has donated a
little bit of money but this is not a
man who's so well connected that he can
get anything done
so again three days later this guy
intervenes again
obviously there's someone must be
someone that's making the executive
decision to form this committee
who's this person at the cpb where's
your manager where's your manager
is he or she willing to get on a call
with congress
unbelievable they will be happy to make
it unequivocally clear
what the rules are in other words if you
guys don't approve our loan application
expect a call from the big guy upstairs
okay expect a call from my lawyer
listen you guys have been complaining
about these karen's because i know they
have videos of them
trying to make a living neighborhood you
go to indian wells you don't see
lawlessness it doesn't matter that you
call them
it brings down quality of life you're
not a police officer you're not a police
officer
i'm a citizen you're not but if you can
do a little bit of imagination
this guy's way worse martin cow is like
twice as bad
he's not saying where's your manager
he's saying you don't get this done
i'm calling i'm calling this editor i
know the senator i've got like
seriously put yourself in this guy's
shoes like imagine the scenario he keeps
going back and forth with him like every
day
he's like hey i need this approved right
now and by the way here's the funny
thing he's extremely entitled for
someone who's lied about his employment
records
according to the doj and this is my
favorite part to perform the above
should take
minutes not days the bank has zero risk
i'm not barking at you yes you are
you're absolutely but you've been
harassing these people for days i'm just
relaying a message from one of the
highest authorities possible in hawaii
can you make sure this message gets to
the correct person
this is a male karen guys
again i know we all watch this person
because it's the spectacle
get away from me
but martin cow is like six times as bad
can you imagine committing fraud and
then getting impatient
that your fraud hasn't been committed
fast enough i if i committed fraud i'd
be like hey you guys take all the time
you need
and i'd be like oh my gosh i hope they
don't find out but i can't believe i'm
getting away with this
i wouldn't say hey get
can you hurry up hey i gotta take my
kids
out on a globe trotting vacation uh and
i'm kind of relying on this money
what what's going on here hey what's
happening
you're crazy dude this is psychotic he
goes
the senator is suggesting a conference
call with his banking committee an
sba staff director she helped write the
ppp rules
hey can you please get this done with so
yeah that's basically it i'll leave the
lawsuit or the complaint letter in the
description below
uh you can read it all if you want it's
it's amazing like i said
i love watching people who think they
have power get taken down a peg
i mean you can bet that if this were
amway or somebody with real political
clout you'd never hear about this
but this guy doesn't he's given a few
hundred thousand dollars he thinks he's
a big guy he thinks he can flex
and at the end of the day they're gonna
call this senator and i don't know what
she's gonna say
but it's probably gonna be like hey
martin who huh
huh that tiny donut no click i hope you
enjoyed this bit of instant karma thanks
for watching
and as always don't forget to smash like
and subscribe thank
[Music]
when you burn through your plastic
stacks
[Music]
a mouth full of money
[Music]
comes along names